wait so how did you get into the wall
trapped yourself that you played Wow I
played Final Fantasy 11 that was my
first MMO on the PlayStation 2 I believe
it was and then I always heard about
well you always hear about well and I
played it like the first time and I
played a lines and I hated it I was like
oh what's going on and like somebody
called me Anu but don't even know what
Anu was and I was just very very
frustrated and then my boyfriend has
some real-life friends who put who
played Wow and wake me and my work had
been together for 14 years so he had
some real-life friends who played well
and he said you want to play with us and
I picked it up and I made like an undead
warrior and I've never looked back yeah
I've heard a lot of it tapes over the
past couple of months Tate is the
division of RTG C which is the Rough
Trade gaming community which is actually
a bunch of LGBTQ people who created a
network of player bases of different
games so taint is the subset that's in
well so who are the WoW presence so
you'll have a difference we have like
Final Fantasy 14 so you and different
presidents over there will have Star
Wars you have a different presence over
there and we are the largest gay gaming
guild out there I think Tate is has over
2,000 members currently in in WoW on
crowd more I think having a safe haven
to go into because when you walk into a
place and you see trade chat or you see
conversations they're not exactly the
most mature conversations and words are
thrown around and you know they might
not have no meaning to the person on
this end but you know to us they mean a
lot so to be able to band together and
feel comfortable and and talk how we
want to talk and you know see somebody
queue and say that they're cute it
really brings us together and I think
you know Wow with having such a huge
player base really brought a lot of
people who don't have the opportunity to
even get together
people and to socialize with them in
game and that's pretty powerful one of
the things that we do do were in the
Proudmoore server is we do throw a
virtual pride
it's the largest virtual pride in any
video game we everybody dresses when
costumes a huge coordination effort we
have a parade we have floats we have we
have float committees we have contest
for the best floats so we're actually
attending a pride in game that you would
normally attend you know in a cities
what's great about that is some people
don't even get to go to pride in the
city and they can come and experience
pride in game and I think that that's
amazing to me are you gonna keep playing
World of Warcraft absolutely I take
Thursday and Friday next week so I
definitely have I think well the
Warcraft will always be a part of my
life in some way shape or form just the
friendships that I've made even if it
does go away I think you will hold a
very special place in my heart and it's
part of my gaming identity so definitely
I definitely played a little rough
you